Speaker 1: Here is a voicemail left on our
voicemail. No, that number is two one nine two
David P.. You can call any time you want, really
whenever you want. It is again about vaccines and
masks, vaccines and masks. Let's take a listen.
Speaker 3: Hello, my name is David, and I want
you to know that I have not going to wear a mask
and I'm a big fan of yours, so we'll take you by.
Speaker 1: That's great. You know. Last week,
we talked about how I got a couple of angry
emails from saying, David, are you an A.M.?
You sound disgusted with masks when you say
when the CDC guidelines changed, I stopped wearing
my mask outside. No, it's very strange how when
the CDC guidelines were wear a mask. Here, there,
there, there, there. I was doing it and I said,
I'm following CDC guidelines and I'm a team
player. And then when the CDC guidelines changed,
I still was saying I'm following CDC guidelines
and doing what the CDC recommends. And a whole
bunch of people got mad at me and they said,
David, no, you should still wear a mask everywhere
all the time. I think it's great that some
people who are vaccinated are still wearing
masks and everybody should assess their risk just
the other day, even though masks are no longer
required in just about any business. I went to
a grocery store and the sign on the door said,
we are still asking people to wear masks. And
I went inside and ninety nine percent of the
shoppers had masks. So I put my mask on.
And to be honest, part of it is because
oftentimes at grocery stores, like one person will
recognize me from the show. The last thing I want
is to be the one person in the grocery store not
wearing a mask. I'm sure the masks will drop off
in grocery stores soon. I know in some parts of
the country they already have in the Northeast,
not quite yet. And then I'll stop wearing
the mask. But I think the great thing about
the mask culture that now exists is hopefully
I've heard people being attacked for wearing a
mask in the south, but hopefully in most of the
country, if people determine that based on their
risk level or their particular health situation
or whatever, they want to continue wearing a mask,
that's great. They should do it and they
shouldn't be made fun of. They shouldn't be
attacked or whatever the case may be that
I think that that that is a great thing.
And as I've said before, if during flu season we
go back to, hey, you know what? When you go to a
grocery store and you're around 100 people
during flu season, maybe you wear a mask.
Maybe we do masks during flu season indoors in
crowded places. That doesn't seem crazy to me,
but no, I am no a.m. I don't see any reason to
wear one outdoors, and I've stopped doing it. I'm
fully vaccinated. I've stopped wearing it indoors
in some places. I was at a cafe over the weekend.
Nobody was wearing masks and I wasn't either.
And that felt fine. And it's fine to wear masks
like I continue doing in grocery stores
because that's what everybody's doing
to each their own. The masks are a good thing,
particularly when we are unvaccinated and we
are slowly going back to the way things were
before. We have a great bonus show for you today.
Get instant access by becoming a member
at Join Pakman dot com. I'll see you then.